7h10 les cheveux dans le dos des cheveux
décolorés le maquillage les lunettes
fumées
le sac à main les pantalons les collants
de couleurs le terreau pensez vous que
votre directeur a eu raison de vous
interdire les chandails et col roulé non
parce que le col le col roulé sert à
tenir chaud et là il est bon l'hiver et
il en le col roulé avec le pull-over
empêche de prendre le blazer ou la veste
élégante qui mène à travers un tablier
se salit les blue jeans
oui parce que ça fait mauvais genre les
chaussures de basket et il a bien eu
raison parce que les chaussures de
basket sont les pieds plats n'échouer
trop long pour les garçons ça fait aussi
mauvais genre et ça fait sale
jusqu'à quelle classe
toutes les classes sont obligés de
porter des blouses même la vôtre même
menés à peu près n'importe et vous pas
que je suis contre la blue se trouve que
le blues détruit toute personnalité puis
enfin quand on voit dans la course a
fait uniforme un peu
non moi je suis contre la douce sommes
plus forts évidemment c'est obligé de la
m je la mets dans les cours mais dès que
je peux m'en débarrasser je l'enlève
vous avez l'impression de travailler
mieux moins bien avec une blouse blanche
la même chose mais enfin je sais pas
quand lorsque j'ai une blouse ben je me
sens un peu un peu diminué j'ai
l'impression qu'on considère comme un
petit garçon de ce que quand on n'est
pas ma blouse
ça fait plus étudiant chez pas
simplement préfère ne pas savoir blues
plus à vous rajeunit un peu trop d'avoir
une blouse se serait jamais une blouse
qui ne me paraît pas bien trop qu'on
était effectivement est assez simple
depuis combien de temps vous l'avez vous
pas lavez-vous fait laver
depuis à peu près six mois c'est moi
ouais mais à l'école la mode est d'avoir
une douce
pourquoi c'est une mode comme ça par
exemple ancien camarade s'ennuie dans un
cours du bouddhisme des blues condesa
lorsque vous supplie très bien quoi
faire on met des couleurs sur la base du
camarade doua j'achète monsieur pourquoi
portez-vous une blouse aussi strictes
puisque je les lirais très étudiants
meeting et alors vous pensez que dès
maintenant vous devez en avoir la ville
ce que je peux dire moi ça me oui je
crois ça vous met dans la peau du
personnage
vous avez quel âge 16 ans et demi et
vous aurez fini votre médecine à quel
âge sachez par sa défense
ça vous fait jamais cette blouse pendant
quelques années encore
et vous monsieur quoi voulez-vous une
carrière scientifique et estimé que le
port de la blouse blanche est
obligatoire dès maintenant
oh oui donc pour un étudiant
scientifique un élève qui a étudié les
sciences de porter une blouse blanche
c'est une tradition dans les classes
syfy eh bien nous voilà édifier les
jeunes de 15 à 18 ans sont sages
pratiques et réfléchie la mode pourvu
qu'ils n'aillent pas dans le sens de
l'exagération intéresse les jeunes sont
les passionnés
n'est ce pas là le signe d'une sagesse
très encourageante
[Musique]